[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
360 الخبر من كل سوايا ومن جميع جوانبه
اوكرانيا تحصد اولى ثمرات هجومها المضاد
بالسيطره على بلدتين وروسيا تنشر صورا
جديده لمقبره دبابات غربيه بدون
اشتباكات عنيفه في الخرطوم وام درمان
وغارات مكثفه للجيش السوداني على مواقع
الدعم السريع
التواصل جدل الاتهامات قبيله محكمه
الثلاثاء محاموت ترامب يؤكدون انه لم
يرتكب اي خطا ولن يقبل باي مساومه
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
صانعوا الذكاء الاصطناعي يحذرون منه مخاوف
من سباق تسلح من نوع جديد
البدايه من تطورات الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد فيبدو ان كياف قد حصدت اولى ثماره
اذ اعلن الجيش الاوكراني استعاده قريتي
جنوب شرق البلد واظهر الجيش مشاهد لجنود
يحملون العلم الاوكراني في بلده
بلاغودانتي التابعه لمقاطعه
يسعدني اعلان تحرير قريه بمنطقه وكانت
عمليه ناجحه ونحن الان نشهد النتائج
الاولى للهجوم المضاد
[موسيقى]
بل مقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التصدي لهجمات اوكرانيه على محور بخمت قبل
ذلك قبل ذلك يا طاهر اعلنت الدفاع التصدي
لهج
وم اذا ورقه مسيره على سفينه تابعه لاصول
البحر الاسود بالقرب من خطي انابيب يقعان
على بعد 300 كيلومتر من القرمه واشارت الى
ان طائره مسيره تابعه لسلاح الجو الامريكي
قامت بعمليه استطلاع اثناء الهجوم
اليوم في تمام الساعه الواحده والنصف
بتوقيت موسكو قامت القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه بمحاوله فاشله لمهاجمه سفينه
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسيه والتي تقوم
بمهام مراقبه الوضع وضمان الامن على طول
طرق التيار التركي والتيار الازرق وخطوط
انابيب الغاز في الجزء الجنوبي الشرقي من
البحر الاسود
تاثيرات الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاده راويه
ومشاهدينا ليست عسكريه فحسب لها جانب
سياسي بحسب تقرير لواشنطن بوست في الجانب
العسكري يزداد القلق بين اوساط النخبه
الروسيه بشان الاسلحه الغربيه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا وما اذا كانت قادره على قطع
مناطق سيطره روسيا في الشرق الاوكراني
والممتده حتى شبه جزيره القرم الصحيفه
نقلت عن مسؤولين روس قولهم ان الدعم
الغربي لاوكرانيا حتى وان لم تنضم
فسيجعلها دوله بجيش حديث تشكل تهديدا
وجوديا لروسيا واشنطن بوست قالت ان روسيا
كانت تعتمد على عامل الوقت وتراجع العزم
الغربي لدعم اوكرانيا خاصه مع امتداد امد
الحرب واحتمال انخفاض مستويات مساعده
اوكرانيا الا ان الوضع على الارض غير
الصوره فهجمات الطائرات المسيره على موسكو
والتوغلات داخل الاراضي الروسيه اثار
التساؤلات حول مدى قدرات الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين على السيطره على الوضع وفق مس لم
يكشفوا عن اسمائهم ورغم تعرض المناطق
الحدوديه الروسيه مثل بلغرود لقصف مكثف
وهجمات سعى الكرملين الى التقليل من تاثير
تلك الهجمات مع تقليل تغطيه التوغلات على
التلفزيون الحكومي لكنه امر لم يمنع من
تصاعد الاستياء احدى علامات توتر النخبه
ظهرت عندما اعلن عضو البرلمان الروسي
بدايه الشهر الجاري فشل اهداف روسيا التي
لم تتحقق في اوكرانيا كالقضاء على النازيه
هناك ونزع سلاحها ووضعها في حاله حياد
التقرير نقل عن مصدر مقرب من الدوائر
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه قوله ان موسكو ربما
ستظهر اشارات متواضعه على انها قد تكون
مستعده لتقديم بعض التنازلات كما نقلت
واشنطن بوست عن دبلوماسيا ان مسار الصراع
في اوكرانيا قد تكون له عواقب غير متوقعه
على روسيا بشكل عام وعلى مكانه الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين بشكل خاص
ينضم الينا من موسكو الان
الدبلوماسيه الروسيه السابق اهلا بك معنا
من كييف دكتور سعيد سلام مدير مركز فيجن
للدراسات الاستراتي اهلا بك كذلك اهلا
بكما لو بدانا يعني بالكلام عن التاثيرات
يبدو الاكيده والمهمه يعني لما تكسبه
اوكرانيا في معركتها المضاده مقابل صوره
روسيا التي بدا انها تتزعزع على الاقل
فيما بين بعض يعني القيادات النخباويه
الروسيه تخوفا على مصير الرئيس نفسه وعلى
مصير روسيا ككل ناهيك عن ادائها في
اوكرانيا ما رايك سيد
انا لا اعتبر ان كل ما هو
وسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه تنشر او غربيه كذلك حول اوضاع
في روسيا او ضعف جيش روسي في موسكو
وفيجيبا الصحيحه نحن نشارك في حرب حرب
ليست في ميدان حرب في سياسه دبلوماسيه
عقوبات اقتصاديه متشرده 12
مجموعه المقوبات وكذلك
الاعلام واذا نحن الان نسمع في انترنت كل
ما هو
الحوارات واحاديث في
اوكرانيه نحن نوجد ان هناك انتشار الكامل
جيشكرين الا ضربوا على جيش الروسي هذا غير
صحيح
اولا ان كما قال صحيح يعني لا ينفع النفي
فقط
انتم امام اعلام قوي جدا شبه عالمي طيب
هذا صحيح ولكن ما هي رواياتكم انت وانتم
ومن يسمعها وعبر اي وسائل ما هي الحقائق
المضاده التي يمكن ان تقدموها مقابل كل
الكلام اللي ذكرناه نقلا عن الاعلام
الامريكي قبل قليل
اولا بدا
الهجوم المضاد كما يسمون في اوكرانيا ونحن
نسميها هجوم اوكراني على قوات روسيه في
دانباز في اتجاه
في منطقه حرقه
هجوم قد بدات منذ كم يوم
وبدات بمجموعه كبيره من القوات من
القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه مسلح
بمدرعات وضبابات وعدد كثير منها في كبده
واحده كان يتواجد في منطقه
ولكن كما اعطوا صوره من
التلفزيونيه من في موسكو انه حوالي خمسه
اشهر
المدرع بين بين خمسه من الدبابات لوبارد
اثنين قدموا على
نعم نعم دعنا نشرك الدكتور سعيد في هذه
المناقشه دكتور سعيد يعني هل برايك هذا
الهجوم المضاد الاوسع الذي كانت تنوي
اوكرانيا القيام به امان نشاهده اليوم رغم
كل المعارك والخسائر هو تحضيري لانه وزير
الدفاع الروسي شيبو تحدث بان القوات
الروسيه المشاركه الان تقدر بلواء حيث
المعارك تدور وبالتالي هل هذا كل ما
ستقدمه روسيا حتى الان
اوكرانيا نعم
روسيا هل ستكتفي روسيا بذلك
بماذا تكتفي روسيا هل ستكتفي بالقوات
الموجوده الان فيما يتم الحديث عنه الان
بانه قوات كبيره تسليح كبير الان تتحضر له
اوكرانيا وبدات به اصلا لانه اليوم خلص
اعلنت عن هذا الهجوم المضاد
طبعا مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين وضحت
الصوره حول السؤال طبعا رغم الجميع
الاعلانات الغربيه
والروسيه حول بدء الهجوم المضاد فانما
نشاهده حاليا هو عمليا عن تحضيرات اوليه
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه لاشن الهجوم
المضاد حيث ان القوات التي تقوم عمليا
بهذه العمليات الاستطلاعيه بالمعارك لا
تتعدى لا تتجاوز الكتيبه اي يعني تعدادها
من 300 الى 500
عنصر جندي وقد تكون معززه ليصل استعدادها
الى الف مع بعض الدبابات الاضافيه
والعربات المدرعه لكن لم نشهد حتى الان
دخول الويه او فراق عسكريه اوكرانيه يعني
من 3000 الى 5000 جندي يقومون بعمليه
هجوميه على محور معين
حاليا العمليات الهجوميه تسعى الى استكشاف
المناطق القوه والضعف لدى الجانب الروسي
ورغم هذا فهي تحقق بعض النجاحات على الارض
وكما ذكرتم في تقريركم فقد تم اليوم تحرير
بعض الاراضي البعض البلدتين اوكرانيتين
اصبحوا ثلاثه الان
ثلاثه طبعا المصادر الروسيه ايضا التي
تشير الى تفجير بعض الجسور في السدود في
مناطق في عمق محور
اقليم زبروجي المحتل من قبل القوات
الروسيه تشير الى المخاوف الروسيه
الحقيقيه من تقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه واختراقها للجبهه اما بعض
المصادر الروسيه ايضا منذ يومين نشرت ان
القوات الاوكرانيه قد اقتربت في بعض
المواقع
خط الدفاع الاول وهناك بعض الاسرى الروس
في حوزه القوات الاوكرانيه بالاضافه
قبل قليل راويه في العاجل على الهواء نقلا
عن
القيادات في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ولكن
انا اريد ان اسالك دكتور سعيد اجبني
باختصار لو سمحت قبل ان اعود الى
هل حتى لو كان ذلك كل انتصارات حقيقيه
وستتبع هل سيكون ذلك في صالح اوكرانيا بان
تحشر روسيا الى هذا الحد في اي مفاوضات
مستقبليه هل سيكون ذلك في صاله في صالحها
في اي علاقات مستقبليه مع روسيا هل سيكون
ذلك في صالحها في علاقات الشعبين بين
بعضهم القيادات بين بعضها ما رايك
وايضا ازاله هذه المعتقدات الشوفينيه
الفاشيه لدى النظام الروسي
والحاكمه الوقيفه يعني اذا كان الهدف
تغيير هذا النظام الروسي هل سيقبل به
الرئيس الحالي فلاديمير بوتين
انت تبتسم وتضحك
هل تسمعني
ما تعليقك على ما تفضل به دكتور سعيد
سيد ماتوز ما تعليقك على يعني
شكرا انا ما فهمت السؤال التوجه
يعني كل التوقعات ان شعب الروسي
يتمرد ضد بوتين ضد سلطه سوريا هذا احلام
الغربيه
وهذا الاحلام تتبنى السياسه غربيه تجاه
روسيا وانا افهم جيدا انه
شعب اوكراني تعاني من تلك المشاكل لازم
ناتجه من كل هذه العمليه حربيه ولكن لا
تنسى ان الشاب الروسي كذلك تزداد
يعني غضبه على تلك الممارسه والخيانه كما
يسمون عندنا الموقف الاوكرانيا
بمواجهه بين روسيا وامريكا بين روسيا
والدول الغربيه بين روسيا وحلف الناتو كل
هذا الان موجه غضب على في روسيا يمكن اكثر
خطوره من تلك الغضب الذي كانت يتحدث عنه
زميلي انا في كيف هذا ليست
موجوده هذا الشعور نحن نفهم جيدا ان نتيجه
هذا الحرب لا يمكن ان يكونوا تزداد حب
للروسيا لقوات روسيا حتى من
الروس عايشين في اوكرانيا هذا صحيح لان
مدمره بيوتهم مدامره مستوى حياتهم وكذلك
فيضان من بلاتين سد
الكخوفكا هذا وحيد لا يجيد الحب للحرب
وينتظرون ان مسؤول ان الحرب هو هي الروسيا
ولكن انا اقول انا هذا ليست الاستدام
اوكرانيا مع الشعب اوكرانيا ان الروسيا
تنظر الى هذاك حرب استراتيجيه حرب
المواجهه طويله الماده مع خمسين الدوله
غربيه ليست
شكرا جزيلا دكتور سعيد فقط للموازنه في
الوقت تعليقك الاخير لو سمحت طبعا مازال
الزميل من موسكو يروج لي الدعايه الروسيه
المضلله حول ان صراعنهم الناتو ضد الغرب
ولكن للاسف الشديد فانهم هم
يروج للدعايه
يروج الدعايه الروسيه التي تنطلق انها
حربها ضد الناتو لكنها بالحقيقه هي حرب
استعماريه
ممتازه امبرياليه حيث انهم يريدون استعاده
الاراضي التي
هي
على استقلالها وهي تناسا زميل ايضا انهم
هم من بداوا العنوان على اوكرانيا
في حرب
وايضا وضمها وايضا اختلاق ما يسمى
انفصاليين في في ودامهم عسكريا واستمرار
الحرب
حتى الان هذا النقاش يبقى مفتوحا شكرا
جزيلا لكما من دكتور سعيد سلام مدير مركز
فيجن للدراسات الاستراتيجيه ومن موسكو
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه في بيان لها
عن عوده 94 عسكريا روسيا من اراضي كياف
وذلك مقابل 95 اوكرانيا اعلنت كياف عن
عودتهم لاراضها وجاء في بيان وزاره دفاع
روسيا ان عوده العسكريين روسيين كانت
نتيجه لعمليه التفاوض الذي تم الاتفاق
عليه وبذلك عاد على اثرها العسكريون من
الاراضي التي يسيطر عليها نظام
واشارت الدفاع الروسيه الى ان الجنود
العائدين سينقلون الى المؤسسات الطبيه
التابعه للوزاره لمواصله العلاج والتاهيل
وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه شاي قدم اوسمه
لبعض الجنود الروس بعدما قالت موسكو انهم
دمروا اربعه دبابات المانيه صنع من طراز
ليو بارد وخمسه عربات مدرعه امريكيه الصنع
من طراز اثناء التصدي لهجوم اوكرانيا
مضاده وظهر شيجو وهو يمنح وسام نجم الذهبي
لبطل روسيا وهو اعلى وسام عسكري روسي
للجنوب
[موسيقى]
وفي العربيه 360 ايضا
نتنياهو يؤكد ان اي اتفاق بين امريكا
وايران لن يكون ملزما
[موسيقى]
لاسرائيل
اهلا بكم من جديد شدد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو على ان تل
ابيب لن تكون ملزمه باي تسويه سيتم التوصل
اليها بين واشنطن وايران كما ستتخذ كل
الاجراءات اللازمه لحمايه امنها
يوم الخميس الماضي تحدثت مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن واكدت على موقفنا
الثابت العوده الى الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران لن توقف برنامج الطيران النووي بل
ستسمح لايران فقط بتوجيه الاموال بمبالغ
كبيره الى اذرعها في المنطقه وحول حدود
اسرائيل شددت على ان اي اتفاق مع ايران لن
يلزم اسرائيل مع او بدون اتفاق سنواصل
القيام بكل ما هو ضروري لحمايه اراضينا
سدد الاجتماع الوزاري لدول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي على اهميه التزام ايران بعدم
تجاوز نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم للاستخدامات
السلميه وضروره التعاون الكامل مع وكاله
الطاقه الذريه كما اكد المجلس في بيان له
على ضروره مشاركه دول الخليج في جميع
المفاوضات بخصوص برنامج ايران النووي وان
تشمل المباحثات كافه القضايا والشواغل
الامنيه لدول المجلس شدد كذلك على ضروره
الحفاظ على الامن البحري والممرات المائيه
في المنطقه والتصدي لكل ما يهدد خطوط
الملاحه البحريه والتجاره الدوليه
والمنشات النفطيه في دول المجلس كما اذان
المجلس اقتحام مقارب بعثات دبلوماسيه لدول
المجلس في السودان مؤكدا ضروره احترام
الاتفاقيات الدوليه والاعراف الديبلوماسيه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات الوضع في السودان افاد مراسل
العربيه بتجدد القصف المدفعي تجاه تمركزات
الدعم السريع في اندرمان
الجيش والد
عم واستخدم فيها اسلحه ثقيله وتمحورت بحسن
مراسل العربيه في وسط وغرب الخرطوم وفي
اندرمان مشيرا الى استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
وخفيفه خلال الاشتباكات في محيط جسر
الحلفايه في مدينه بحري شمال الخرطوم حيث
توالت الانباء حول سيطره الجيش عليه
وكاله الطاقه الدوليه تطلب اذا اتاحه وصول
خبراءها لخزانات
الخزانات كخوفكا التي يعني تبرد محطه
زابوريجيا اخر الاخبار العاجله اما
المتحدثه الاقليميه بالعوده الى موضوعنا
السابق المتحدث الاقليميه بسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر فكانت قد ذكرت بان
فرق الحمايه التابعه للجنه في السودان
تستقبل اتصالات دائما للابلاغ عن حالات
فقدان بافراد من العائلات السودانيه منذ
بدء الصراع قبل حوال شهرين وبحسب المتحدثه
لم تتوقف البلاغات حتى الان مع مرور كل
يوم مع استمرار عمليات البحث عن المفقودين
المبلغ عنهم وشددت ايضا على ان عمليه
التقص
واجهتها عوائق عديده ابرز الاقتتال
المستمر وشرح الامكانيات والموارد الطبيه
حيث تعيق عمليات التعرف على الجثامين او
على انتشالها
[موسيقى]
انتشرت سلطات المصريه المركب الذي احترق
قباله ساحل البحر الاحمر بعد ان قالت ان
ثلاثه مواطنين بريطانيين فقدوا بعد ان
اشتعلت النيران في قارب غطس كانوا على
متنه قباله الساحل على البحر الاحمر كما
قالت محافظه البحر الاحمر ان 12 من افراد
الطاقم و12 سائحا بريطانيا تم انقاذهم
عندما اشتعلت النيران في المركب قباله
مدينه مرسى علم
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
طبعا الان وكاله الطاقه الدوليه تشدد على
ضروره التاكد من منسوب المياه في سد كخفقه
لتبريد محطه زابوريجيا طبعا هذا السد الذي
تم استهدافه منذ ايام قليله واثرت المياه
على العديد من القرى الاوكرانيه نتابع من
بحث الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مع ثلاثه من
قاده الاتحاد الاوروبي ملفات عده ابرزها
مكافحه الهجره غير النظاميه حيث اعلن اعلن
عن تخصيص مئه مليون يورو لتونس من اجل
احتواء تدفق المهاجرين نحو اوروبا هذا وقد
شددت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه على ان تونس
اولويه بالنسبه لايطاليا وان اي زعزعه
للاستقرار فيها سيكون له تداعيات خطيره
على استقرار منطقه شمال افريقيا باكملها
وان التداعيات ستصل ايضا الى ايطاليا
[موسيقى]
شارع رئيس هيئه الدفاع عن الرئيس العراقي
الاسبق صدام حسين الدكتور خليل الدليمي في
مقابله خاصه للعربيه خلال برنامج الذاكره
السياسيه اجراها معه الزميل طاهر براكي
بان ضباطا من الجيش الايراني حضروا تنفيذ
الحكم بحق صدام حسين وكان يتكلمان باللغه
الفارسيه اعدام صدام حسين هل حضر ضباط
مخابرات ايرانيون
كم كان عددهم لماذا
اثناء صعود الرئيس الله يرحمه على يعني
الدرجه وصاعد على المنصه اتكلموا حتى
يثبتوه لانه احنا اللي حاكمناك تكلموا
بالفارسي حتى يوصلوا للرساله انه احنا
اللي حكمناكم الامريكان
يعني عقابا على حرب ثمان سنوات
بالفارسي تقول بالفارسي نعم كان حدا عم
يترجم له يعني بس هو من الغايه كان اسماع
صوت اللغه الفارسيه حتى لو بدون ما بدون
ترجمه الوصول الوصول لصوتهم باللغه
الفارسيه خلص انه ايرانيين موجودين واللغه
الفارسيه معروفه هل فعلا حضر قاسم سليماني
اعدام صدام حسين لا اعتقد
من صور الاعدام مريم الرئيس وموفق الربيعي
وهل كان يقولان امور معينه يعني اللي صدام
حسين او لغيره الرباعي كان يعني يشتم
بالرئيس وكان خايف هو نفسه
من بغداد ينضم الينا الدكتور مناف الموسوي
رئيس مركز بغداد للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اهلا بك سيد مناف معنا يعني رايك
بالتصريحات التي سمعناها هل برايك فيها
مبالغه يعني عم نتحدث عن وجود ضباط
ايرانيين عندما تم اعدام الرئيس السابق
صدام حسين
ومشاهدي قناه العربيه نعم انا اتفق معك
انه هنالك مبالغه كبيره من قبل المحامي
وبالتالي اولا يعني الذي اعتقل رئيس
النظام السابق هم الامريكان والامريكان
كانوا هم من يعني يقومون بحمايه
وتامين وصوله الى المحكمه وخروج من
المحكمه انا اعتقد ان المحكمه التي قدمت
الى الزعيم
رئيس النظام السابق لم تقدم الى اي دكتور
في العالم محكمه علنيه امام الجميع
وبالتالي يعني اعتقد اليوم ان المحكمه لم
تنصف او لم تتحدث اليوم عن مجموعه جرائم
التي يعني قام بها هذا النظام او رئيس
النظام السابق للشعب العراقي هنالك اكثر
من
شهيد استشهد
يعني بدون بدون ذنبه بدون محاكمه يعني
الجزء الاكبر منهم يعني اهاليهم لم تستلم
جثثهم ولم تقوم بعمليه دفنهم واعتقد ان
المقابر الجماعيه كانت واضحه بهذا بهذا
الشكل وبالتالي المبالغه واضحه من قبل
المحامي والحديث بهذا الشكل واضح يعني هذا
فقط لموضوع هذا حضور الضباط الايرانيين او
في ملفات اخرى ايضا عرضها معنا دكتور
دليمي يعني هو تحدث عن عثمان صدام حسين
نقل الى منزل نوري المالكي رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق في حفل زفاف ابنه احمد لكي تعرض
الجثه التشفيا منه هل يعني هناك ما ينفي
ذلك خاصه مع وجود فيديو على اليوتيوب يقال
ولا يمكن ان نؤكد ذلك بانه هناك
يعني كما تفضلت اولا اللي هو لا يمكن ان
نثبت ذلك حتى نقوم بعمليه النفي يعني
اعتقد يفترض اذا كنا مسلمين لان عمليه
التشفي بالميت هي عمليه غير مقبوله وغير
لكن بالنتيجه انا اعتقد ان يعني المحاكمه
محاكمه صدام حسين
يعني كانت اقل من الجرائم التي نفذت في
ابناء الشعب العراقي لم يكن الشعب العراقي
فقط يعني هو من يعني حدثت لهذه الجرائم
ربما يعني دول الجوار ايضا يعني تسلا من
هذا الموضوع واعتقد مع حدث في الكويت واضح
بهذا الشان بالنتيجه اليوم
لا اريد ان اتحدث عن الميت يعني ليس
بطبيعتي ان اتحدث انا عن الميت ولكن اقول
انا شخصيا من عائله تم اعدام احد افرادها
يعني واجبرنا على دفع اطلاق يعني الرصاصات
التي تم عمي فيها
ومنعنا من اقامه عزاء في ذلك الوقت وكانت
تنصب يعني
سرادق
يعني الافراح
امام امام منزلنا هكذا كان يتصرف النظام
السابق وهكذا كان يتعامل مع ابناء الشعب
خلينا نشوف مقطع اخر الحديث
مفهوم ونعتذر على التقليب مواجعك الشخصيه
في هذا الموضوع ولكن هذا شان يخص يعني
ايضا كل العراقيين دعنا نطلع على جزء اخر
من المقابله قبل ان نعود اليك ادلاني اشار
الى ان الحبل الذي نفذ به اعدام صدام حسين
كان مكونا من 39 عقده وهو عدد الصواريخ
التي اطلقتها بغداد ضد تل ابيب ابانا حرب
الخليج
هل صحيح انه عدد عقد الحبل حبل المشنقه
كان على عدد صواريخ التي ضربها صدام حسين
على اسرائيل هذا ما نقل من داخل قاعه
المحكمه قاعه الادم
39 39 نقطه
على عدد الصواريخ التي قصف بها اسرائيل
هل مات شنقا فعلا
كانت كانت عمليه اعدام عمليه غوغائيه
يعني انت تؤكد لنا الشكوك حول
موته شنقا نعم عمليه غوائيه عمليه اعدام
من اطلاق الشعارات الى التهديد الى اخر
مرحله
هو الذي رفض فعلا وضع الكيس نعم
عندما تقول غوغائيه يعني تتجاوز الشنق
هكذا تفسر
ماذا كان دور الضباط الايرانيين
ايثار رساله انه احنا اللي عدمناك فقط
في معلومات تقول انه كان عندهم اهداف اخرى
متعلقه بالتاكد من هويه من يقومون باعدامه
ربما
يعني اخذوا مثلا
اشياء معينه من جسده للدي ان اي للفحوص
لا اعتقد
ماذا حصل بالجثمان بعد الوفاه
نقل الى بيت نور المالكي تشفين
في يوم زواج
نجله احمد
دكتور ملف الموسوي رئيس مركز بغداد
للدراسات الاستراتيجيه من بغداد مجددا
اهلا بك بغض النظر عن مدى دقه او صحه هذا
الكلام من عدمها الا ينبغي اعتبار ذلك
بمثابه اخبار
وبدء القضاء بالتحقيق بمثل هذه المعلومات
التي ترد عبر الفضاء المفتوح وعبر الاعلام
العربي
اولا انا اقول يعني ليس من تباعنا كمسلمين
اليوم لا التشفي في الميت ولا
الاستعمال بعد يعني بعد بعد الموت لان
بالنتيجه انتقل الى الى عالم اخر لا
استطيع ان اتحدث لا بالنفي ولا بالاثبات
باعتبار انا لمشاهد هذه المساله ولكن اقول
يعني انما قام بهذا النظام هو افضع بكثير
مما يتحدث عنه اليوم البعض واذا كانت
هنالك ممارسات من بعض يعني من بعض قاده
هذا يعني هذا هذا هذا هذا النظام السياسي
الجديد اعتقدهم من يتحملون وزر هذا هذا
العمل
المسؤوليه دكتور
يعني اذا كان اذا كان هذا الحديث صحيح
بالتاكيد يتحمل المسؤول عن عمليه الاعدام
القائد العام رئيس الوزراء في تلك الفتره
يفترض هو من يتحمل واقول انه هنالك الكثير
من القضايا في هذا في هذا المجال يعني
اليوم ايضا
الموضوعات ايضا بتحميل المسؤوليات حتى لو
حملت هذه المسؤوليات لانه التيارات
السياسيه تخاصمت وتنازعت كثيرا في شخصيات
ايضا تسلمت مناصب مهمه جدا في الدوله
اسمها يدخل ايضا في هذا السياق لماذا لا
تدعو الى محاكمتها ايضا
طبعا يعني انا انا حقيقه من خلال قناتكم
الكريمه ادعو بمحاكمه كل من تسبب سواء كان
في قتل اي مواطن عراقي او احدث اي جريمه
كانت من اي يعني من اي جهه كانت سواء كانت
شيعيه او كرديه او سنيه متواجده على على
مستوى القياده ربما نحن دائما من نتحدث عن
مظلوميه ان واخواننا في الجانب السني
وندعو اكثر من سياسيين اهل السنه لكشف
المصير المغيبين والبحث عنهم وبالتالي
ايضا قد نتعرض الى ضغوطات وتهديدات من قبل
الجماعات الموجوده اليوم سواء كانوا في
السلطه ولكن بالنتيجه اليوم يعني لا نريد
ان يكون القياس قياس ديكتاتور سابق انتهى
واخذ يعني اخذ مصيره من خلال محاكمه علنيه
وبين ابرياء اليوم او او بين مجرمين
موجودين صاروا على نهج هذه الشخصيه على
العكس انا اطالب كل من كانت له يد في
عمليه
قتل المواطن العراقي او تهجيره او تغييبه
او الى اخره اتمنى ان تكون هنالك اداه
حقيقيه وان يتم محاكمته واقول اليوم ان
هنالك الكثير من القضايا التي ربما دائما
ما اطرحها اقول ان جريمه العصر جريمه
سبايكر والتي راح ضحيه اكثر من 2700 مواطن
عراقي بدون سبب دائما ما ندعو الى عمليه
كشف ما كان وراء هذه العمليه ومحاسبتهم
محاسبه قتله المتظاهرين ندعو وبالتالي
يعني انا اقول ان اي مجرم في اي فتره
زمنيه لابد ان ياخذ عقابه سواء كان اليوم
او حتى بعد فتره يعني بعد فتره من الزمن
شكرا جزيلا لكن من بغداد الدكتور مناف
الموسوي رئيس مركز بغداد للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا الشرطه
الاسكتلنديه تطلق سراح رئيسه الوزراء
السابقه بعد التحقيق معها في قضايا ماليه
اهلا بكم من جديد بدي اطلقت شرطه سراح
رئيسه وزراء اسكتلندا السابقه
دون توجيه اي اتهامات لها وذلك بعد ان
القت القبض عليها في اطار التحقيقات في
الشؤون الماليه للحزب الوطني
الحاكمي المؤيده للاستقلال
[موسيقى]
اعتبرت محاميه الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب وحلفاء له ان الاحتفاظ
بمستندات بعد مغادرته البيت الابيض بصفتها
تذكرات شخصيه او وثائق رفعت عنها السريه
كانت ضمن حقوقه مستنكرين الملاحقات
السياسيه التي يتعرض لها بدوره قال رئيس
اللجنه للشؤون القضائيه بمجلس النواب
الجمهوريه جيم جوردن لشبكه تي ان ان قدره
الرئيس على التصنيف والتحكم في الوصول الى
معلومات الامن القومي مستمده من الدستور
بالاضافه على السريه عن هذه المواد ويمكنه
وضعها في اي مكان يريده ويمكنه التعامل
معها كما يشاء
صوره صادمه رسمتها اوراق البيت الابيض
السريه التي احتفظ بها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق في مرحاضي وغرف نوم منزله في
فلوريدا اوراق حملت اسرار الحكومه
الامريكيه حول برنامجها النووي وخططها
العسكريه واجازاتها الاستخباراتيه التي من
المفترض ان يتم تقاسمها فقط بين المسؤولين
الامريكيين وفق اكسيوس لكن ما فعله ترامب
بعد صدور لائحه الاتهام ضده التي شملت 37
تهمه هو الظهور مرتين في كل من جورجيا
مستانفا حملته الانتخابيه مهاجما للجميع
ومدافعا عن صورته
انتم تشاهدون كيف يحاول جو بايدن سجن
منافسه السياسي الرئيسي فكر قليلا بذلك
هذا تماما ما يفعله قاده دول العالم
الثالث الذين يفضلون سجن خصومهم بدلا من
مواجهتهم انتخابيا الامر واضح وبسيط
على كثرتها طالت الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
بدات بان بايدن يسعى لوضع ترامب بالسجن
لتجنب منافسته وصولا الى اتهامه بتلقي
اموال من الصين للاحتفاظ بسناديق مليئه
بالوثائق السريه كلمه لم يسلم منها الا
قليل طالت هانتر نجله بايدن ايضا الذي اكد
ترامب ان المكتب الفيدرالي لديه ادله
دامغه على تلقي نجل بايدن اموالا طائله من
اوكرانيا لحاكم فلوريدا روندي سانتس نصيب
وافل من خطابه ايضا حيث وصفه ترامب بانه
بلا شخصيه ولا يستطيع الفوز في الانتخابات
القادمه
لا يزال مقتنعا بان الوثائق التي يملكها
ارشيفيه وليس سريه وبان الجهات الفيدراليه
يجب الا تشارك في محاوله اتهامه اياد حمود
العربيه
وثائق البيت الابيض السريه لم تكن امنه
فاين احتفظ بها ترامب اكثر من 80 صندوقا
ملات غرفه التخزين في منزل ترامب ست صور
نشرت تظهر صناديق من الورق المقوى للوثائق
مكدسه في غرف منزل ترامب فيمارااجو
الرئيس السابق وبحسب وزاره العدل وضع
الوثائق السريه في المرحاض وقاعه الرقص
وغرف النوم وفي نادي الجولفي الخاص به في
نيوجيرسي شبكه بي بي سي افادت بان
الصناديق التي تحتوي على مواد سريه كانت
مخزنه على منصه في قاعه الرقص البيضاء
والذهبيه حيث جرت الفعاليات والتجمعات
[موسيقى]
هل سيكون الذكاء الاصطناعي اذكى من البشر
هذا هو السؤال الان وهل سيتحول لسلاح قاتل
كما شاهدنا في افلام الخيال العلمي
تساؤلات مطروحه خاصه بعدما اعلن قبل ايام
مات كليفورد مستشار رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني لشؤون الذكاء والتكنولوجيا ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن ان يصبح قويا بما
يكفي لقتل العديد من البشر في غضون عامين
فقط التحذير هذا كان ايضا دعوه لوضع نظم
وتشريعات لمنتجي ومطوري الذكاء الاصطناعي
على نطاق عالمي كي لا تخرج الامور يوما
معا السيطره لاحقا جدد سام التمان المدير
التنفيذي لشركه اوبن اي ال مخاوفه وقال ان
التوتر جعله يصاب بالارق بعد اطلاق روبوت
الذره
ان اطلاق هذا الروبوت للدردشه ليس شيئا
سيئا الا ان المخاوف تتمثل في ان يستغل
احد هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي وحذر من تسببه
في انقراض البشريه لكن وعلى الرغم من
توالي التحذيرات الى ان خبراء تقنيه
توقعوا بان لا يخرج الذكاء الاصطناعي عن
سيطره الانسان على الاقل في المدى القصير
المنظور ومع ذلك قال خبراء ان الخطر
الاكبر في الذكاء الاصطناعي ليس خروجه عن
السيطره بل في استخدامه بشكل سيء من جانب
الدول او حتى الشركات المتطوره او ان يكون
الذكاء الاصطناعي ساحه لسباق تسلح من نوع
جديد في العالم لكن في حال ما اذا كان او
اصبح الذكاء الاصطناعي اذكى او اقوى من
المبرمجين فكيف ستتعامل الحكومات مثلا مع
اي حوادث مستقبليه
مفهوم الذكاء الاصطناعي والتقنيات العامله
به ينعكس على تحديد مسؤوليه المبرمج عن
اخطاء هذه التقنيه على سبيل المثال في
حاله حدوث وفاه ما المسؤوليه الجنائيه
المترتبه على هذه الاخطاء
بسبب غياب التشريعات حتى اللحظه يرى
مختصون اهميه وضع قوانين لدراسه التطور
السريع لهذه التقنيه كما خرجت دعوات
لافتراض مشاكل واضرار مستقبليه قد تنجم عن
الذكاء الاصطناعي والاته لوضع المجتمع في
صوره العقوبات ومنع وقوع اي تخبط عند وقوع
اي ضرر كبيرا كان ام صغيرا
[موسيقى]
تواصل قوافل الحجاج توافدها الى مكه
والمدينه في طريقها الى المشاعر المقدسه
استعدادا لاداء مناسك حج هذا العام وست
استعدادات كبيره من قبل الجهات المعنيه في
السعوديه لتسهيل حركه تنقلاتهم داخل
المشاعر ووسط توقعات بتدفق ملايين الحجاج
الى المشاعر المقدسه خلال الايام المقبله
وعملت الجهات المختصه على تجهيز 160 الف
مخيم لاستقبال الحجاج في مشعري من وعرفات
حيث تم تزويد هذه المخيمات بكافه الخدمات
التي يتطلبها الحاج
[موسيقى]
اثار تعيين اردوغان لابراهيم كالين رئيسا
لجهاز الاستخبارات اهتماما في الشارع
التركي لجهه التساؤل حول درايته يا طاهر
بالعمل الامني وخبايا لكن مواهب كالون
الاخرى كانت طوال الاسبوع الماضي حديث
الشارع
تشكل اله الساز تراثا موسيقيا في تركيا
فهي معشوقه الفنانين وكثير من الهواه
يفضلونها ولا يقتصر الاهتمام بها على
الفنانين فقط فهناك رياضيون وكتاب
وسياسيون ايضا برعوا في العزف على هذه
الاله الموسيقيه اوضح مثال على ذلك رئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات الجديد
يلا
تلقى اغاني ابراهيم كلين رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات الجديد صدى واسعا عند الجمهور
في تركيا فهو عازف ومغني محترف وكاتب
ومتخصص بالفكر الاسلامي والفلسفه شغفه
بالموسيقى والغناء لم يمنعه من احتراف
السياسه والعمل الامني فهو احد مستشارين
السياسيين والامنيين لاردوغان في السنوات
الماضيه
عملت مستشارا لابراهيم كالان لمده خمسه
اعوام هو شخصيه متنوعه له عده نشاطات يهتم
بالفن وبالفلسفه والادب عمل كثيرا وبشكل
متصل مع رئيس الاستخبارات السابق هاكان
فيدان وكان من ضمن فريق النخبه الامنيه
والسياسيه للرئيس اردوغان انتقاله الى
جهاز الاستخبارات شكل مفاجاه للكثيرين لكن
المقربين منه ومن عمل معه يؤكدون انه على
درايه بمعظم الملفات الامنيه لذلك لم يكن
قرار تعيينه مفاجئا لهم
منذ عام 2018 وهو يعمل كرئيس للجنه سياسه
الخارجيه والامن في رئاسه الجمهوريه وهي
اللجنه التي عملت فيها مستشارا له وان لم
يكن له توصيف رسمي لكن السيد كالين كان
المستشار الاول للرئيس اردوغان في قضايا
الامن وسياسه الخارجيه ايضا كان وكيل
الرئيس في اداره لجنه الامن القومي
في استحقاق ابراهيم كلين الجديد لن يعزف
على اوتار السياسه وتقلباتها فقط بل هو
مطالب باداره ملفات امنيه اطلع عليها في
سابق عمله كمستشار وناطق اعلامي باسم
الرئاسه زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
صيح اليوم لا يوجد اي اساس لاي حوار ممكن
مع اوكرانيا هذه تصريحات المتحدث باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه الذي اكد في المقابل عدم
وجود اي شروط مسبقه لاجراء محادثات محتمله
معك اعتبر ايضا ان اوكرانيا لا ترغب
بالمفاوضات وغير مستعده لها طبعا تصريحات
المسؤول الروسي تتزامن مع الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من اوكرانيا
انها منطقه ريفيه في مقاطعه خيرسون او ما
تبقى منها بعد ان غمرت المياه كل شيء
مرور نحو اسبوع على كارثه السد الا ان
هناك من ينتظر قوارب الن
حرب ليست بحرب فسلاحها اليدان اما الذخيره
فهي فطيره انها بطوله العالم لرمي فطيره
الكاسترد في مقاطعه كانت جنوب انجلترا 120
متنافسا شكلوا 30 فريقا وارتدوا ملابس
تنكريه وحتى ان كانت القذيفه ليست فطيره
حقيقيه فهي مصنوعه من مزيج الدقيق والماء
ولذيذه ايضا ربما
[موسيقى]
صهيب شراير معه اخبار الساعه الان مع
انتهاء العربيه 360 مساء الخير صهيب
اعتقدت انك ستلقي علي فطيره كاستر
انت عارف انت
مساء الخير طاهر وراويه اهلا بكم بالفعل
فتره الاخباريه المسائيه مستمره اخبار
الساعه بعد قليل في الصداره تبقى اوكرانيا
وتطورات الملف النووي الايراني الذي يعود
من جديد
تفضل شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات